um so you guys are from uh Brooklyn
right yeah
bad side are you from bedside well you
guys know about MLP yeah we was just
talking about that smash out Posse my
favorite rap groups ever
Brownsville home of the brave putting
work in the street like a slave
what you know about that like one of my
favorite rap groups ever oh [__]
is Brownsville still because there was a
double XL article when I was a little
kid and they interviewed MLP and I
remember they were talking about how
they would like they were just saying
how crazy Brownsville was I always just
assumed Browns was like the craziest
place on Earth is it still that bad oh I
mean it's probably worse yeah
the gentrification hasn't hit
Brownsville yet I mean they trying right
but it's not doing nothing
because the danger the crime is scaring
the white people away yeah
and the hipsters
well ladies who don't shave their
armpits all types of shoes independent
coffee shops
never go to a Starbucks you gotta
support the Indies uh how long have you
guys been rapping
um I mean I've been rapping my whole
life but
I just started taking this [__]
when I was seven for me okay seven so
say I said seven you were rapping when
you were six months old I mean obviously
I could even talk when I'm six months
you said your whole life sir bro same
[__] seven seven see the rappers you
were seven yeah I was a kid but I just
started taking it seriously so two years
ago two years ago what was there like a
catalyst for you that like made you take
it serious
it should go viral or not like a life
hit me like I graduated high school and
I realized I had to do this all in my
life yeah I had to do it my parents
wanted me to go to college but I didn't
want to do that [__] I wanted to find my
own path and my passion was music so I
chose my passion I still what about you
how long you been rapping uh I'm gonna
rap for like two years now you started
two years ago yeah I started rapping two
years ago Jesus but um music like it's
been involved like I played instruments
before I started rapping like I've been
in a band before I saw your dad's like a
music teacher yeah you know what's crazy
he was yeah yeah like was he like the
music teacher at the at the school like
you know no no he was not specifically
for my school but you know he had an
interest in music so I guess it's a
genetic thing like even before the
rapping I just love music what
instruments you play I played trumpet
piano
um I tried to do guitar and drums
have you decided like have you busted
out any of the instruments for any
production yet nah but recently I've
been thinking about it it'd be kind of
hard yeah I probably yeah I will learn
trumpet again Trump would be I was good
at it yeah that was great it was the
best of my class so were you like
because you know I think when you're
like really good at instruments can't
you travel and like do like shows and
[__] like yeah yeah we started doing
shows like we had an independent group
in my school that I went to we started
doing shows but it was mainly just like
you know in the city We Were Young
couldn't really go that's fire
for two years two years yeah yes so you
were starting to rapping during the
pandemic
we was like we was in a crib I was going
through a lot
like a lot for me it was just a lot of
time on our hands and stuff you know
and you guys did you guys graduate high
school during the pandemic
yeah like I have a problem my graduation
was on a football field like this
[__] I feel like the pandemic was
like six months ago but like it's like
it's just crazy to think like I feel
like we're still in a pandemic I don't
know how to explain it that should
change everybody you think like uh had
the pandemic not happen you guys
wouldn't have like focused in on the
music maybe I ended up doing something
else that's a good question me
personally
I know I probably wouldn't be rapping I
don't know the pandemic nah it just
striked a lot
it was good for me I mean I don't know
man I caught covered three times but I
did call kova too
you did you yeah just once did you guys
get the jab
good job what's the job [__] vaccine
oh
what the job uh yeah
we got one
so what the [__] was the purpose of the
job
I don't know I don't know we won't dive
into that because we want to make sure
this YouTube video stays up